y la derivación o revascularización
coronaria cada vez por su sigla en
inglés se realiza para mejorar la
circulación hacia el músculo del corazón
en personas con enfermedad de las
arterias coronarias walterio patía
coronaria grave en este procedimiento se
conecta o injerta una arteria o una vena
sana de otra parte del cuerpo en la
arteria coronaria obstruida
la arteria o la vena injertada puente a
la parte obstruida de la arteria
coronaria transportando sangre oxigenada
al músculo del corazón se puede realizar
el puente o de una o más arterias
coronarias en una misma operación
antes de la cirugía se le colocará una
vía endovenosa y es posible que se les
suministre algún medicamento para
ayudarle a relajarse los procedimientos
de cabell se realizan con anestesia
general por lo tanto estará dormido el
tiempo que dure la operación se
insertará temporalmente un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y hacia la
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación se le colocará un
catéter en la vejiga para drenar la
orina la cirugía de revascularización
coronaria por lo general lleva entre
tres y seis horas en una cirugía
convencional de revascularización el
cirujano primero realiza una incisión en
la piel sobre el hueso del pecho o
esternón
el cirujano luego cortara el esternón y
desplazará la caja torácica para llegar
al corazón durante todo el procedimiento
su sistema circulatorio estará conectado
a una bomba o máquina de derivación
cardiopulmonar
durante la cirugía esta máquina realiza
temporalmente las funciones del corazón
y los pulmones lo que permite detener su
corazón para que el cirujano pueda
suturar los injertos en su lugar para
los injertos se utilizan por lo general
uno de estos dos vasos sanguíneos la
arteria torácica interna del pecho o la
vena safena de la pierna para el injerto
de la arteria torácica interna
el cirujano dejará el extremo superior
conectado a la arteria subclavia na y
desviará el extremo inferior desde la
pared del pecho hasta la arteria
coronaria apenas pasando la obstrucción
luego el cirujano suturar a el injerto
en su lugar
para el injerto de la vena safena el
cirujano suturar a un extremo a la aorta
y el otro extremo a la arteria
estrechada apenas pasando la obstrucción
con los injertos asegurados en su lugar
el cirujano usará señales eléctricas
para restablecer el ritmo cardíaco y
colocará temporalmente un marcapasos en
el corazón
una vez que el corazón recupere el ritmo
cardíaco normal se desconectará la
máquina cardiopulmonar
unirá nuevamente el esternón con alambre
especial para cirugía y suturar a la
incisión de la piel para cerrarla se
colocará en forma temporal un tubo de
drenaje a través de piel por debajo de
la incisión recientemente se han
desarrollado otros dos tipos de
procedimientos cada vez la cirugía de
revascularización sin bomba y la cirugía
de revascularización mínimamente
invasiva la revascularización coronaria
sin bomba también se denomina injerto de
revascularización a corazón latiendo
debido a que no se detiene el corazón y
no se utiliza máquina cardiopulmonar en
cambio se utiliza un dispositivo
mecánico para sujetar firmemente la
parte del corazón donde se está
realizando el injerto los cirujanos
realizan procedimientos de
revascularización mínimamente invasivos
utilizando instrumentos especialmente
diseñados para ello que se insertan a
través de pequeñas incisiones o puertos
en el pecho estos procedimientos a veces
requieren que se coloque una máquina
cardiopulmonar después de la cirugía se
lo trasladara a la unidad de terapia
intensiva se monitoreará cuidadosamente
la actividad cardíaca de ser necesario
se utilizarán temporalmente los
electrodos del marcapasos para contra
su ritmo cardíaco el tubo del pecho
permanecerá en su lugar para drenar el
exceso de sangre y aire de la cavidad
torácica una vez que pueda respirar sin
ayuda se le retirará el tubo
respiratorio y se le colocará una
máscara de oxígeno el catéter de la
vejiga permanecerá en su lugar a medida
que se recupere durante los siguientes 3
a 4 días se le irán retirando
gradualmente todos estos dispositivos